So how would you use a production system to design an agent that
can solve Raven's Progressive Matrices. We could think about this kind of at
two different levels. At one level we could imagine a production system that's
able to address any incoming problem. It has a set of rules for what to look for
in a new problem and it knows how to reply when it finds those things. But
on the other hand, we can also imagine production rules that are specific to
a given problem. When the agent receives a new problem, it induces some
production rules that govern the transformation between certain figures and
then transfers that to other rows and columns. So in that way, it's able to
use that same kind of production system methodology to answer these problems,
even though it doesn't come into the problem with any production rules written
in advance. So, inherent in this idea though, is the idea of learning from
the problem that it receives. How is this learning going to take place? How is
it actually going to write these production rules, based on a new problem? And
what's the benefit of doing it this way? What do we get out of actually having
these production rules, that are written based on individual problems?